but really nutty Hall came here to hear
us talk about reason TV I know why
you're really here and it's to hear me
talk about love
well there's 7 billion people walking on
this world of ours how I found the
perfect girl think about the odds
I think somebody up above at us
exchanging glances I mean what are the
chances it's like if victims of improper
screenings all had the same views and
that guy at the agency told Congress
that ain't true and it turns out when he
said that that it really was a myth and
the lady in charge of it all happened to
plead the fifth now while that's all
coincidence I don't think our romance is
I mean what are the chances
what's the next verse oh yeah
now while we're on the subject of
stories no one buys you can't tell me
how we met girl ain't just fate in
disguise regardless how improbable it
seems that all romances what are the
chances it's like a fan impartial agency
with no corrupt connections leaked
private tax returns which were then used
to sway elections and the hard drive of
the lady at the center of the buzzin
conveniently lost all the emails from
the time in question so the Congress
asked for records from a second dude as
well but it turns out there weren't any
cuz is our drive crash as well so they
tried to get some records from a third
person and fourth but wouldn't you know
their hard drives crash so no emails of
course and the fifth person and six
person were focused on for help and they
finally found that no their hard crash
crash as well then a seventh person and
a seventh person's hard drive cash I'm
telling you it's true I guess what I'm
trying to tell you girl is I love you
thank you
you